welcome everybody it is a major major 24
hours of news we have uh all sorts of
different things going on economically
including what's going on
in the stock market the expected fed
announcement today about interest rates
which a lot of different people are
watching for different reasons be it
geopolitically or economically or
financially or whatever the case may be
we're also going to be talking about uh
foreign policy and geopolitics today and
uh just a lot going on so to start with
really major statement yesterday
from the department of justice there's
been this question for months now
which quite frankly to put it coarsely
the question is like what the hell is
the doj doing are they going to
investigate any of the
dozen different things that they could
investigate related to what republicans
and the trump campaign did and tried
around the 2020 election what is merrick
garland doing now the answer on most of
those things is still no they're not
investigating but a pretty major piece
of news yesterday an admission from the
deputy attorney general lisa monaco who
said
there is an active investigation
into one element of the trump coup plot
which is the fraudulent republican
electors now i'm trying to think should
i play the clip first or should i
explain what that let's play the clip
first where she acknowledges that there
is an investigation going on then then
i'll remind you
there's so many aspects to the 2020
trump coup attempt that i'll i'll
explain which one she's referring to
on the issue you raised in terms of
fraudulent
elector certifications as has been
reported we've received those referrals
our prosecutors are looking at the at
those and um i can't say uh anything
more on ongoing investigations
but more broadly um look uh the attorney
general has been very very clear we are
going to follow the facts and the law
wherever they lead uh to address conduct
of any kind and at any level
that is part of an assault on our
democracy so at any level is of course
code for up to and including the
president that's good to see
but specifically she says there is an
active investigation going on into the
elector scam now let me remind you we we
have such a
in many countries if we said
the thing they tried with the election
is being investigated it would be one
thing it would be like okay they tried
messing with absentee ballots
or they tried manipulating voting
machines or
they lied to people about what the
voting hour like there would be we would
know what it is
with the trump attempt in 2020
it's five or six different things and
the one that lisa monaco is referring to
is the idea of sending an alternate
fraudulent set of electors to cast votes
within certain states for trump instead
of biden so i'll remind you of one state
where they they did it the idea was this
arizona
joe biden won arizona not controversial
to say that uh in the world of sanity
reason empiricism and logic joe biden
won arizona
republicans fixated on arizona as one of
the states where they said
trump actually won
now on january 6th 2021 as as we now all
know
those electors
those votes were formally accepted
uh in washington dc some of them carried
over into january 7th because of the
riots the idea that they had was
sign up create a document that says here
are the electors from arizona and they
would be republican electors even though
joe biden won
send them to be the ones to say arizona
casts its electoral votes for donald
trump with the idea that mike pence
would be the one to say
due to the dispute and fraud and
whatever in arizona we are accepting
these republican electors instead of
these democratic electors it was an
insane long shot and of course it didn't
happen and mike pence didn't participate
that's the scam and it looks like rudy
giuliani ran that and that they were
trying it in seven or so states
that is what lisa monaco says
is under investigation so
that's a good thing it's a very big deal
and we will continue to follow it of
course
one of our sponsors is cometeer coffee
cometier coffee is delicious i can tell
you firsthand and they've discovered the
best way to brew preserve and deliver
coffee their brewing process captures
over 2 000 flavor compounds then the
coffee is flash frozen locking in the
flavor it arrives at your home frozen in
a fully recyclable capsule all you have
to do is melt it by adding hot water or
cold water for iced coffee it takes
seconds it's the most convenient way
that i have ever made coffee i've been
impressed with how the process protects
the flavor i really enjoy cometier they
have a variety of flavor options light
medium and dark single origin and
blended coffee roasts from the best
specialty roasters you'll get twenty
dollars off when you go to cometeer.com
pacman the link is underneath this video